I studied the 10 most powerful Empires
over the last 500 years and the last
three Reserve currencies it took me
through the rise and decline of the
Dutch Empire and the Gilder
the British Empire and the pound
the rise and early decline in the United
States Empire in the dollar and The
Decline and Rise of the Chinese Empire
and its currencies as well as the rise
and decline of the Spanish German French
Indian Japanese Russian and ottoman
Empires along with their significant
conflicts
as measured in this chart
to understand China's patterns better I
also studied the rise and fall of
Chinese dynasties and their monies back
to the year 600. because looking at all
these measures at once can be confusing
all focus on the four most important
ones the Dutch British U.S and Chinese
you'll quickly notice the pattern
now let's simplify the form of it as you
can see they transpired an overlapping
cycles that lasted about 250 years with
10 to 20-year transition periods between
them
typically these transitions have been
periods of great conflict because
leading Powers don't decline without a
fight so how am I measuring an Empire's
power
in this study I used eight metrics each
country's measure of total power is
derived by averaging them together they
are education inventiveness and
Technology development competitiveness
in global markets economic output share
of World Trade military strength the
power of their financial center for
Capital markets and the strength of
their currency as a reserve currency
because these powers are measurable we
can see how strong each country is now
was in the past and whether they're
rising or declining
by examining the sequences from many
countries
we can see how a typical cycle
transpires
and because the Wiggles can be confusing
we can simplify it a bit to focus on the
pattern of cause effect relationships
that drive the rise and decline of a
typical Empire
as you can see better education
typically leads to increased Innovation
and Technology development and with a
lag the establishment of the currency as
a reserve currency
you can also see that these forces then
declined in a similar order reinforcing
each other's decline
let's now look at the typical sequence
of events going on inside a country that
produces these Rises and declines in a
nutshell the big cycle typically begins
after a major conflict often a war
establishes the new leading power and
the New World Order because no one wants
to challenge this power a period of
peace and prosperity typically follows
as people get used to this peace and
prosperity they increasingly Bet On It
continuing they borrow money to do that
which eventually leads to a financial
bubble the Empire share of trade grows
and when most transactions are conducted
in its currency it becomes a reserve
currency which leads to even more
at the same time this increased
Prosperity distributes wealth unevenly
so the wealth Gap typically grows
between the rich Haves and the poor
have-nots
eventually the financial bubble bursts
which leads to the printing of money
and increased internal conflict between
the rich and the poor which leads to
some form of Revolution to redistribute
wealth this can happen peacefully or as
a civil war while the Empire struggles
with this internal conflict its power
diminishes relative to external rival
powers on the rise when a new Rising
power gets strong enough to compete with
the dominant power that is having
domestic breakdowns external conflicts
most typically Wars take place out of
these internal and external Wars come
new winners and losers that then the
winners get together to create the New
World Order and the cycle begins again